[Music]
what is up guys
so basically in this video all I'm doing
is dismantling items and getting the
solar scales and then selling them for
profit let's get started into the video
so I already bought some so I'm buying
the serpentine Helms uncharged and then
dismantling them and turning them into
Zora scales and that is how I'm making
my money you make money as long as you
buy everything under two million seven
hundred forty thousand the reason for
that is because I sold my solar scales
for one hundred thirty-seven GP each
which in turn makes you a profit of
about anywhere between twenty to forty K
per helm i buy the Helms for a little
over two point seven mil this one bought
for under two point seven minutes
just buy them with however much cash you
have and sell the scales and then buy
more if you have more money you can make
more money if you have less money you're
going to make about the same as me
because I had to buy the helm and then
sell the scales immediately I soon
realized that you could also buy the
toxic blowpipe uncharged and also make
about 30k profit so I decided to do that
and keep making more money the buy limit
for serpentine Helms and for the toxic
blow pipes on charges eight so I did
eventually reach the buy limit for the
helmet so I kept buying the toxic blow
pipes at this part I had about five of
them and I was just buying and selling
them as quick as I could selling the
scales and buying the blowpipe so after
I reached my buy limit for the helmet
and for the toxic blow pipes uncharged I
decided to look up what other items can
you take apart for twenty thousand
Zoeller scales and I realize you can do
it with the CERP helm Vistage and you
can also do it with the tanzanite thing
and both of those will make profit the
problem was is I tried buying both of
them and neither of them would sell so
I'm not sure if the buy limit is linked
to the Helms and the toxic blow pipes on
charge or not alright I'll show you guys
how much money I made now the amount of
money I made from the solar scales was
twenty-one million nine hundred twenty
thousand times - and then I - the 21
million six hundred three thousand seven
hundred forty-seven from the server time
Helms and then I - the 21 million seven
hundred six thousand one hundred nine
thousand from the toxic blow pipes and
that equaled five hundred thirty
thousand so I made five hundred 30k and
roughly forty minutes this is insane
profit you can make over a mill an hour
thanks for watching guys stay tuned for
my next video